[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
michael rodgers qui il a été l'homme le
plus riche de russie avant de se
brouiller avec vladimir poutine il a été
accusé de fraude fiscale et a passé plus
de dix ans en prison une accusation
qu'il a toujours affirmé être une
vendetta contre lui il a été libéré en
2013 et il vit à londres où il a fondé
le ng open rachat il est avec nous
monsieur rocard three bienvenue sur
france 24
bien sûr je vous salue
pourquoi est-ce que vladimir poutine a
lancé cette guerre en ukraine monsieur
claude en corse qui quel est son but
d'après vous
l'ukraine a sombré mais 14
après
s'être libéré viktor ianoukovitch qui
était en vassal de poutine
avec ces deux façons aux tensions de pur
dans le sens moral monsieur beauty et il
considère que tout ce qui s'est passé en
ukraine des puits c'est l'entraînement
des américains pour qu lui le pauvre
poutine soit privé du four et pendant
toutes ces années poutine chercher me
pas au
départ
donnait la possibilité à le cren devenir
un pays
à part entière et en ce moment
c'est un petit peu la réaction
émotionnelle
c'est une décision émotionnelle qui est
lié au fait qu'il voit et qu'il constate
que les situations pour lui ne se
développe pas de façon positive vous
dites émotionnel on a entendu certains
responsables occidentaux américains
notamment se poser des questions
j'allais dire presque sur la santé
mentale de vladimir poutine est-ce que
vous pensez que il est devenu
irrationnel où est-ce qu'au contraire il
a construit cette opération de façon
très circonstancié en réfléchissant bien
et en sachant exactement ce qu'il allait
faire
sur le plan médical
bien sûr non il est pas c'est pas un fou
complet non bien que certains signes
apparaissent de la paranoïa ceni nous
constatons cela lorsque nous on nous le
voyons derrière cette longue très longue
table derrière laquelle il et rencontre
son entourage et la peur d'être tués
cependant bien que de façon clinique ce
n'est pas fou
l'opération était planifiée avec
beaucoup d'erreurs et et ça c'est le
problème de tous les leaders autoritaire
plus que vingt ans après elle et ses
leaders
perdent
la possibilité de voir
l'information adéquate
on leur dit qu'ils sont glorieux et
grands et y prennent des décisions
correctes et poutine était sûr que en
venant en ukraine il sera accueilli avec
des fleurs
puisque il libère le peuple ukrainien de
la honte l'ukrainienne donc pour lui
c'est une façon une attente inattendue
est ce qu'il fait d'après vous une
erreur historique
erreur historique oui sans doute
puisque il avait les situations tout à
fait stable à l'intérieur de la russie
et leur bus est parfaitement d'être en
tête de la pyramide du pouvoir jusqu'à
sa mort jusqu'à sa mort besoin
puisque les gens n'étaient pas près
de perdre
à cause des changements de façon
révolutionnaire et les gens ne pouvaient
pas changer le pouvoir
par la voie électorale poutine a
arrêté cette possibilité maintenant
c'est que c'est un suicide
il ne peut pas gagner en ukraine même
s'il arrive à prendre qui est faux
kharkov et ceci a précipité sa fin vous
pensez vraiment que c'est le début de la
fin pour vladimir poutine alors il ya
d'une part ces sanctions qu'ils ont sans
doute plus sévère qu'il attendait mais
toute la question que tout le monde se
pose c'est est ce que les élites
politiques sécuritaires militaires voire
économique qui jusque là le soutiennent
vont peut-être le lâcher parce qu'il
considère peut-être sans le dire jusqu'à
maintenant qu'il fait en effet une
erreur fatale
récit la russie a bien sûr une certaine
expérience cette expérience était une
boîte installée
s'est passé il y a plus de s'entraîner à
moscou il est clair que
dans leurs visites le cas où il n'arrive
pas à gagner à nice rennes et à mon avis
il ne peut pas y gagner
et donc après cela ce le régime lui-même
qui va se composer il va se décomposer
pas de façon rapide entre un et deux ans
pendant ces années soit poutine va
fermer complètement le pays et en faire
un territoire d'autarcie qui va passer
du siec du 21e siècle au 19ème siècle et
à la fin ce sera la chute totale chute
économique puisque les contradictions
internes entre les républiques
nationaux ou qui verront les autres les
voisins
ceci va déchirer le pays complètement
mais il ya une autre possibilité une
autre version qui montre que après il
faut deux ans après la fin de
cette
ex et militaires
cet ex amis etc ces militaires qui se
termine par une révolution je pense que
poutine et sur cette voie alors on a vu
des manifestants en russie contre la
guerre ils ont été rapidement arrêtés et
réprimer on a vu certains médias
indépendants la radio echo de moscou la
chaîne de télévision doj qui ont été
fermés il y a quelques jours est-ce que
vladimir poutine craint que les gens ne
n'accepte pas en russie cette guerre et
que cela puisse le déstabiliser ou
est-ce qu'il a clairement encore les
choses en main
samedi sans doute sans aucun doute vous
mener d'ici là des actions il agi par
instinct et il agit de façon saccadée
et qui ce qui montre qu'il a peur du
changement de l'opinion publique si
l'opinion publique en russie c'est
plutôt
une opinion qui soutiennent la guerre
contre le crâne puisque les gens
déclare que ce n'est pas contre le
peuple ukrainien nous libérons l'ukraine
contre les nazis contre les partisans de
bendera et nous n'avons pas de perte du
tout donc il n'y a pas de sens pas
d'effusion de sang et ça c'est l'opinion
qui était formée par propagande chez des
gens ordinaires mais cette opinion va
être détruit certainement sous l'
influence des faits simples
et s'est fait ce seront des cercueils
qui vont arriver en russie
deuxième chose qui va changer c'est
ce sont les prix que la population verra
les prix à cause du blocus de la russie
à cause
donc ça va durer pendant quelque temps
pendant quelques semaines et boutines
veut le ralentir par un ralentissant
l'accès à l'information pourquoi elle
veut ralentir parce que s'il
finit s'il termine elle la campagne
militaire il va lancer ses troupes pour
contre les protestants protestataires
puisque maintenant pour
contrecarrer les protestations il est
obligé de dénuder sa campagne militaire
alors c'est pas bon pour lui l'opposant
emprisonné alexeï navalni un drap depuis
sa prison appelé aujourd'hui les russes
je le cite à manifester tous les jours
contre la guerre en ukraine est ce que
vous vous joignez à cet appel alexeï
navalni où vous considérez que ce n'est
pas le moment où c'est pas la bonne
méthode face à vladimir poutine
- dire je soutiens
cette proposition
de sortir et de protester le 6 mars le 6
mars samedi
je fais appel à tous les russes de
sortir dans les rues le 6 mars pour
protester contre la guerre en ukraine je
considère
que c'est un facteur décisif
pour
obliger poutine a retiré une partie des
troupes je suis aujourd'hui les
ukrainiens mais est-ce que les gens
la possibilité de sortir tous les jours
dans la rue
je ne peux pas dire qu'ils aient et
je serai tout à fait content si le
potentiel des gens suffirait comme le
prédit navale n'est juste toute dernière
question très rapidement ce qu'on a plus
beaucoup de temps est ce que vous
craignez un conflit nucléaire
il y a encore une semaine
j'aurais rigolé mais je ne peux pas rire
maintenant je pense que août il était
tout à fait prêt pour utiliser les armes
nucléaires tactiques mais je suppose
quand même
il n'est pas que c'est un pas un
fanatique pourra stocker deux fois avec
des armes nucléaires un pays qui est
parvenu
clair je veux rappeler que les
etats-unis
la grande-bretagne aussi bien que la
russie sont les garants du mémorandum de
budapest qui recchi
qui était le refus du statut nucléaire
pour le cren et je pense que les
obligations de ce statut
feront tout pour convaincre
poutine qu'il n'est pas nécessaire et ce
ne veut pas le coup terminer cette
guerre mais cette guerre se terminera
pour lui par l'emprisonnement il pensera
que il n'est pas quand même
utile de mettre en péril toute la
destinée de l'humanité pour vérifier si
les etats-unis et la grande-bretagne
exécute ses obligations sur le la cour
de budapest
il reste encore ce qui je vous remercie
beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et six sur france 24
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cet
entretien est resté sur notre chaîne
pour plus d'informations
[Musique]